enquête
maurice papon va se retrouver jeudi le
nouveau devant un tribunal mais cette
fois ci c'est lui qui porte plainte il
poursuit en diffamation l'historien jean
luc einaudi pour ses propos dans le
monde sur la répression de la
manifestation algérienne du 17 octobre
61 en quête de nos confrères de france 3
2 france 3 et manuel gagner bruno
l'hiver tout ce soir là lorsqu'il sort
du métro wazemmes saada les mains sur la
tête pour se protéger des coups de
matraque
comme des milliers d'autres algériens
sur ans de l'uefa l'aisne le mouvement
indépendantiste
il est venu manifester pacifiquement à
paris contre le couvre feu les forces de
l'ordre les attendent en ce moment là
comme ça
à faire sur nous un carnage est happé
par tous les moyens qu'ils avaient d'un
sous les 20 on peux pas vous dire cesser
des barres de fer ou les matraques ou
des coups de crosse bilan officiel de la
répression policière trois morts 200
d'après le fln une centaine selon cet
ancien responsable syndical de la police
était notre organisation or tous nous
ont dit que l'on 7001 ils ont reçu plus
d'une centaine de canard et que pour
évacuer on rejetait souvent les canards
à la scène les raisons de ce
déchaînement des forces de l'ordre les
attentats du fln contre les policiers
dans les mois précédents mais aussi ce
17 octobre d'étranges rumeurs sur les
ondes de la police il a été dit que des
collègues auraient été tirés auraient
été abattus par part des nord africains
s'étaient entièrement fond mais pour
certains le responsable de ce drame se
serait maurice papon alors préfet de
police de paris après ces paroles
dramatique pour un coup reçu nous en
rendrons 10 mais dans le climat qu'il
avait à ce moment là dans les formations
ça a été interprété inévitablement pour
un tué en nature à 10 cet ancien
collaborateur de maurice papon est
formel le fln porterait la
responsabilité des violences on pouvait
pas tolérer qu'ils aillent manifester
sous les fenêtres du général de gaulle
nous l'accorderez dans même s'était pas
pensable c'était pas pensable pomme et
etc aurait pensé l'armée française en
algérie
alors quand alors qu'on essaie tout
faire ici ce n'est pas possible un débat
sur lequel la justice va se pencher à
partir de demain les juges devront dire
si l'historien jean luc einaudi à
diffamer maurice papon en affirmant
publiquement que l'ancien préfet était
responsable de la mort de plusieurs
centaines d'algériens
police